La France est la nation chrétienne par excellence.
A travers son histoire
se sont souvent écrites les plus belles pages de la Chrétienté.
C'est le pays qui possède le plus grand nombre de saints, dont saint Martin l'apôtre de la gaule.
Sainteté et royauté ont façonné la France.
Par le baptême de Clovis,
la France est non seulement la fille aînée de l'église,
mais aussi le premier État d'Europe et l'un des plus anciens du monde.
Par le sacre de Charlemagne,
l'Empire des Francs, qui s'étend alors sur la France, l'Italie et l'Allemagne,
unifie la Chrétienté d'Occident et devient le berceau de la civilisation européenne.
Par la première Croisade,
derrière le pape français Urbain II et le chevalier Godefroy de Bouillon,
la France se fait le fer de lance de la Chrétienté combattante à l'étranger.
Par saint Louis, modèle du roi chevalier, l'art politique se double d'une haute dimension spirituelle.
Magnifiée par ces saintes patronnes que son l'immaculée vierge Marie, la guerrière Jeanne d'Arc
et la pêcheuse d'âme Thérèse de Lisieux,
la France élève la femme à ses plus nobles aspirations.
La cathédrale,
symbole de l' architecture française,
hérisse ses pointes de pierres vers la cime des cieux et illumine de ses vitraux les consciences humaines.
Les chansons de geste,
mémorial littéraire de la France,
présente l'épopée de héros chrétiens, tels Roland et Olivier, qui affrontent géants et Sarrasins.
Quant à l'avenir de la France, selon des prophéties, un Grand Monarque de souche française
viendra sauver l'Europe chrétienne à l'heure de son plus grand péril.
L'histoire de la France,
l'histoire de la Chrétienté
et l'histoire de l'Europe se confondent au point qu'aucune ne saurait s'écrire sans les deux autres.
La défense de l'Occident chrétien est un concept fondateur de l'identité française.
D'où l'importance de Charles Martel.
La première dynastie des rois de France est celle des Mérovingiens.
Les plus grands rois mérovingiens furent Clovis, Clotaire II et Dagobert Ier.
Après Dagobert, commence la période des rois fainéants.
L'autorité publique passe alors entre les mains des Maires du palais, une sorte de Premier Ministre qui gère le royaume à la place du Roi.
Le premier de ces gouverneurs, Pépin l'Ancien, est l'ancêtre des Pippinides et l'arrière-grand-père de Charles Martel.
C'est à Éginhard, biographe de Charlemagne, que l'on doit la célèbre citation sur les rois fainéants :
Fruit de cette confusion politique,
divers barons en viennent à revendiquer la mairie du palais de leur région, et un climat de guerre civile s'installe.
En 687,
Pépin le Gros,
descendant de Pépin l'Ancien, est alors maire du palais d'Austrasie,
le Nord-Est de la France.
A la bataille de Tertry, il remporte une victoire décisive,
qui lui permet de réunir entre ses mains la plus grande partie du Royaume des Francs.
C'est un tournant.
Jusqu'à Dagobert,
l'unité du Royaume ne pouvait se faire qu'autour d'un roi;
à partir de Pépin le Gros, c'est autour du maire du palais que se fait l'unité du pays.
Dans les banquets festifs qui arrosent la victoire de Tertry,
Pépin le Gros délaisse son épouse Plectrude pour sa maîtresse Alpaïde.
De cette union adultérine naît en 688 Charles Martel.
Une chronique de l'époque décrit brièvement l'adultère de Pépin le Gros et le caractère de son fils illégitime.
Bien que bâtard, Charles Martel reçoit une éducation de prince.
Il apprend à monter à cheval et s'exerce au maniement des armes,
discipline virile où ressort son tempérament de chef, qui lui attire de solides amitiés.
C'est aussi dans ces années d'apprentissage que Charles vit ses premières amours.
Puis le preux chevalier épouse une jolie demoiselle du nom de Rotrude.
Charles et Rotrude auront deux fils,
Carloman et Pépin le Bref,
ainsi qu'une fille, Aude
Pepin le Gros meurt en 714.
Conséquences fâcheuses de la vie dissolue du patriarche, la succession se passe mal.
D'un côté,
Plectrude entend assurer seule la régence durant la minorité de Théodoald, un enfant de 6 ans,
qui est le petit fils légitime.
La veuve obtient le soutien de plusieurs évêques influents, tels Lambert, l'évêque de maastricht,
et Rigobert,
l'évêque de reims.
De l'autre,
Charles revendique pour lui même la mairie du palais et compte sur sa garde rapprochée pour satisfaire ses desseins politiques.
Lors d'un plaid, l'assemblée des barons décide de confier l'autorité à Plectrude.
Pour se prémunir contre tout coup d'État,
la régente ordonne aussitôt d'arrêter son fillâtre Charles et de le jeter dans les geôles de son palais de Cologne.
Mais Plectrude n'a pas l'étoffe de feu son époux,
et les régions autrefois réunies sous la poigne de Pépin le Gros reprennent leurs divisions.
Rainfroi, duc d'Anjou, était le chef militaire de la Neustrie, une région qui correspond au nord-ouest de la France.
Ambitieux, il rêve de devenir l'homme fort du royaume et se prépare à la lutte.
Le 26 septembre 715, près de Compiègne, il remporte une victoire sur les Austrasiens de Plectrude.
C'est le début d'une succession de batailles entre Francs.
Au cours de la mêlée, Rainfroi réussit à s'emparer du roi Dagobert III.
C'est un acte important,
car le roi, bien que fainéant, est la légalité vivante.
Qui tient le roi, tient le pouvoir.
Rainfroi se fait introniser maire du palais de Neustrie,
puis il fait supprimer Dagobert III et nomme un nouveau roi, Chilpéric II, qui est bien sûr sa créature.
La guerre civile franque tourne bientôt au conflit international.
Les Neustriens s'allient aux païens frisons.
Ensemble, ils vont assiéger Cologne, où s'est retranchée Plectrude. Et le siège porte ses fruits.
Au printemps 716, pour s'éviter un malheur plus grand,
Plectrude achète la paix et remet un lourd tribut aux envahisseurs.
Le bilan politique de Plectrude est calamiteux.
L'Austrasie est vaincue, ruinée, humiliée.
Alors, dans la panique, on organise un nouveau plaid, et les leudes choisissent cette fois de s'en remettre à l'homme providentiel
qui croupit dans le cachot humide.
Plectrude est congédiée. L'Austrasie se donne à Charles Martel.
Le chef des Francs de l'Est prend immédiatement l'initiative.
Avec ses fidèles, il se rue à la poursuite des Neustriens de Rainfroi et Chilpéric II.
Le 8 juillet 716, à Amblève dans les Ardennes, Charles tend une embuscade aux Neustriens,
qui fêtent dans l'ivresse leur récent triomphe de Cologne.
Se croyant à l'abri du danger, les soldats de Rainfroi et Chilpéric prennent du bon temps sous l'épais feuillage,
tandis que le vin et le soleil d'été engourdissent les consciences.
Soudain, au signal convenu, les Austrasiens assaillent l'ennemi,
et Charles remporte une première victoire sur Rainfroi, qui s'échappe sans gloire.
Un hiver passe.
Puis, le 21 mars 717,
Charles remporte une deuxième victoire, à Vincy, près de Cambrai en Flandre.
Sûr de sa puissance, il pousse son avantage jusqu'à Paris et entre dans la capitale du royaume.
Fort de son triomphe militaire,
Charles retourne à Cologne, où il se fait introniser maire du palais d'Austrasie.
En guise de caution dynastique, il place à ses côtés un Mérovingien de pacotille,  Clotaire IV.
C'est en Aquitaine que Rainfroi et Chilpéric trouvent refuge.
L'aquitaine est alors quasi autonome.
Cette région, douce et latine, est dirigée par Eudes, un duc pragmatique assez âgé.
Rainfroi expose à Eudes les déboires de la Neustrie et réclame son aide contre Charles Martel.
Le duc de Toulouse accepte.
Une coalition est ainsi créée, qui unit la Neustrie et l'Aquitaine.
Les intentions du duc d'Aquitaine sont évidentes.
Faisant sien le vieil adage "diviser pour mieux régner",
Eudes espère alimenter la guerre civile chez ces turbulent voisin du Nord.
Mais Eudes a dangereusement sous-estimer son adversaire.
Le 14 octobre 719, Charles Martel écrase la coalition à Néry en Picardie.
Une paix est finalement signée entre Charles et Eudes, Francs et Aquitains n'ayant aucun intérêt à la poursuite de ce conflit.
Les rois Clotaire IV et Chilpéric II sont assassinés.
Et Charles nomme un nouveau et unique roi pour tout le royaume, Thierry IV.
Quant à Rainfroi, il s'en retourne seul dans son fief angevin et se résignera lui aussi à la paix.
Entre 714 et 721, il y aura eu quatre rois fainéants :
Dagobert III,
Chilpéric II,
Clotaire IV et Thierry IV,
jouets malheureux entre les mains avides des deux maires du palais : Charles et Rainfroi.
Grands vainqueurs de la guerre civile, Charles tient désormais seul les rênes du pouvoir.
A la fois audacieux et prudent, il est le véritable chef de l'État, sans remettre en cause la monarchie héréditaire.
Ayant assis son autorité et réalisé l'unité des Francs,
Charles va pouvoir se consacrer aux affaires étrangères.
Par la nature des choses,
Gaule et Germanie sont voisines.
Leurs querelles ou leurs amitiés ont souvent rythmé les événements d'Europe de l'Ouest.
La Gaule jadis était païenne.
Au tréfonds des forêts feuillues, ses druides présidaient aux destinées de la patrie et au sacrifice en l'honneur des dieux.
Bercé par le chant sacré des bardes, les guerriers y prononçaient le serment politique avant de partir au front.
Mais les défaites de Vercingétorix
en -52
puis de Boadicée en Bretagne en l'an 61 avaient finalement conduit les Celtes à intégrer l'Empire romain.
Aussitôt connectés aux divers réseaux de l'Empire, les Celtes purent acquérir les savoirs gréco-latins
et dès l'époque des évangiles
participer activement à la naissance de la civilisation chrétienne.
En s'émancipant du paganisme,
Gaule et Bretagne ont ainsi enfanté des saints, des abbayes et des textes littéraires.
Au contraire des Celtes, les Germains avaient réussi à repousser les légions conquérante du latium.
La victoire d'Arminius en l'an 9 épargna aux Germains l'insertion à l'Empire.
Mais cette liberté sauvage eut un prix.
Elle les aura isolés de la marche du monde et de l'essor du christianisme, et ce pour de nombreux siècles.
Durant le Haut Moyen Age, les hôtes de l'Europe centrale vécurent toujours à l'orée de l'histoire.
Au VIIIe siècle, on en voit les conséquences.
Alors que la Gaule chrétienne a fait son unité politique
et dispose d'un État central fort sous l'égide de Charles Martel,
la Germanie peine à se trouver,
émiettée en une myriade de tribus régies par des roitelets tantôt chrétiens tantôt païens.
Pourtant le rapport de forces est plus subtil qu'il n'y paraît, car l'anarchie n'est pas toujours gage de faiblesse militaire.
De mémoire d'homme, à l'époque, jamais la Germanie n'a été conquise par personne.
Ni le grand César,
ni l'empereur Auguste,
ni plus tard les rois mérovingiens Clovis, Clotaire II, Dagobert,
personne n'est jamais parvenu à envahir ce territoire d'Europe centrale aux frontières floues et aux
populations disparates.
Comme ses prédécesseurs, Charles a maille à partir avec les belliqueuse tribus qui hantent les forêts d'outre-Rhin.
Notamment, vers 720, il lance une violente offensive contre les Saxons.
Mais, à défaut de vaincre l'hydre païenne,
l'Occident doit sans cesse repousser la menace du chaos germanique, et tout reste à refaire.
Par ailleurs, depuis déjà plusieurs générations, des missionnaires chrétiens avaient pris pied sur le sol germanique.
Là, avec patience et abnégation,
les serviteurs de Dieu s'efforcent d'enseigner aux masses indigènes les préceptes du Sauveur.
Mais les couvents,
trop épars et mal défendus, sont constamment l'objet de pillage de la part de roitelets païens.
Cette double percée, des armées franques et des communautés religieuses,
se fait séparément.
D'où leur manque de résultats durables.
Alors le pape Grégoire II prend une initiative.
En novembre 723, il invite à Rome un moine anglais déjà célèbre pour son apostolat en terre païenne du Nord.
Ce moine,
C'est Winfried, plus connu sous le nom de saint Boniface.
Le pape confie à Boniface le périlleux évêché de Frise sur l'estuaire du Rhin,
avec la charge de poursuivre sa croisade contre les tribus échevelées de Germanie.
le Saint Père italien fait aussi de l'apôtre anglais son messager auprès de Charles Martel.
L'idée de Grégoire II est d'associer la puissante armée des Francs à l'éloquence dialectique des moines.
La tâche est inédite et promet d'être efficace : c'est l'alliance officielle de l'épée et de la crosse.
Quant à Charles,
saisissant l'occasion d'accroître son emprise sur la Germanie tout en servant la puissante église,
il donne aussitôt son accord.
Dès 725, le maire du palais envoie ses armées sur la Souabe puis sur la Bavière
pour en pacifier les territoires rebelles.
Les années suivantes,
d'autres percées militaires suivront au gré des nécessités à briser la témérité païenne et à soutenir l'élan missionnaire.
Sa femme Rotrude étant décédée, Charles profite de ses campagnes étrangères pour en ramener une demoiselle
bavaroise du nom de Sonnehilde, qu'il épousera en secondes noces.
Ainsi, la première action internationale de Charles Martel est d'avoir oeuvré avec énergie
à l'expansion de l'influence franque à l'est du Rhin et à la christianisation de la Germanie.
Si le maire du palais était mort envers 730, il aurait déjà laissé de lui le souvenir d'un chef d'état courageux et intelligent :
il a gagné la guerre civile de 714, il a continué l'unification de la Gaule,
il a consolidé la puissance militaire du Royaume,
de là, il a été sollicité par le pape Grégoire II pour aider à l'évangélisation de l'Europe centrale.
Ce bilan politique, déjà méritoire, n'est pourtant pas ce qu'ont retenu en premier de lui les générations suivantes.
Un péril mortel s'approche de l'Europe chrétienne.
Et l'Europe chrétienne ne le sait pas encore.
Dans les sables chauds d'Arabie, une autre civilisation,
une autre race, une autre religion émergent.
Le prophète Mahomet naît vers 570 à La Mecque et meurt en 632 à Médine.
Le fondateur de l'islam a environ 40 ans
quand il commence la rédaction de ce qui va devenir le Coran.
Mais nul n'est prophète en son pays.
Ses premiers prêches ne convainquent pas.
Il doit fuir La Mecque pour Médine à 300 km au nord.
Cette fuite,
hégire en arabe,
correspond à l'an 1 de l'ère islamique.
A Médine, les populations lui font en revanche bon accueil.
C'est la création du premier État islamique au monde.
A la mort de Mahomet, ses successeurs poursuivent l'extension de l'État islamique.
Toujours en quête d' espace à convertir, vers l'an 700,
l'un des tentacules de l'armée musulmane est déjà aux portes de l'Espagne.
Depuis la chute de Rome,
l'Ibérie était en grande partie gouvernée par les Wisigoths,
un peuple de souche germanique, qui s'y étaient installés lors des grandes migrations aux IVe et Ve siècles.
Or ce royaume wisigoth, qui date pourtant de près de trois siècles, est gangréné par une guerre civile.
En 711, une troupe musulmane traverse la Méditerranée
et opère un premier débarquement en Andalousie.
Ces musulmans sont des Arabes mais aussi des Berbères fraîchement convertis.
A la bataille du Guadalete, les mahométans, emmenés par le général Tariq,
écrasent l'armée germanique.
Rodrigue, le roi des Wisigoths, y trouvent la mort.
C'est l'effondrement.
Bientôt le gouverneur omeyyades Musa débarque à son tour avec de gros renforts.
Poursuivant sur leur lancée, les disciples d'Allah absorbent la presque totalité de la péninsule Ibérique.
Connus désormais sous le nom de Sarrasins, ils placent leur capitale à Cordoue.
Les conquérants islamiques sont accueillis favorablement par
l'influente communauté juive,
dont les intrigues locales ont pu faciliter l'invasion.
L'Ibérie vaincue, les musulmans y font venir leurs familles.
Cette première vague de Sarrasins comprend environ soixante mille immigrés.
Il y en aura beaucoup d'autres au fil du temps.
Quand plusieurs communautés doivent partager le même espace vital,
la règle de vie n'est pas le métissage,
mais l'affrontement où la ségrégation.
Les peuples obéissent en effet aux mêmes instincts que les animaux.
L'islam n'est pas à proprement parler une religion spirituelle.
Très éloigné du message d'amour et de liberté de l'Évangile, le Coran est en fait une
constitution politique.
La loi coranique ou charia
réglemente tous les domaines de la vie :
la prière et l'aumône, certes, mais aussi la nourriture,
le vêtement, le port de la barbe et même les procédures à respecter pour l'héritage ou les métiers de la banque.
Dans l'islam, tout est codifié.
Le livre saint des mahométans étend ses tortueuses sourates à tous les domaines de l'existence :
rues, boutiques,
administration, armée, vie intime.
Le but ultime de l'islam consiste en l'instauration d'un califat totalitaire à l'ensemble du monde.
Quant aux peuples qui refuseront la parole du prophète,
celui-ci leur réserve un statut discriminatoire :
la dhimma.
le mot dhimma signifie "protection" en arabe.
Les dhimmis, c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont soumis à la dhimma, ont obligation de s'acquitter d'un lourd impôt
envers la communauté musulmane.
Et ils ont entre autres
interdiction de porter des armes,
interdiction de mettre une selle alors cheval,
interdiction d'élever la voix devant un musulman,
interdiction de faire des processions religieuses,
Interdiction d'avoir un clocher plus haut que le minaret.
A l'occasion, les nouveaux maîtres n'hésitent donc pas à transformer de belles églises séculaire en mosquées.
En Andalousie islamique,
les nouveaux venus décident de battre monnaie.
Et la légende de ces pièces est riche d'enseignements.
Dès 716, les dinars sont bilingues :
latins et arabes.
En 720, le latin disparaît, ne reste que l'arabe.
L'archéologie ne témoigne d'aucun métissage idéologique.
Par exemple, l'islam d'Espagne n'intègre pas d'élément chrétiens.
A partir de 711, l'Ibérie européenne et chrétienne plonge dans les abysses et sort de l'histoire.
Durant le Haut Moyen Age, les juifs possèdent l'insigne privilège du trafic d'esclaves en Europe.
La plaque tournante de ce juteux commerce est Verdun.
Les esclaves sont des païens de souche germanique ou slaves.
Une marchandise blonde aux yeux clairs, que les fils d'Isaac revendent au prix fort en Espagne sarrasine au Maghreb.
De leur côté, les musulmans se livrent à la piraterie.
Ils font des razzias sur les côtes méditerranéennes de l'Europe du Sud, trop exposées et mal défendues.
Les Sarrasins y capturent des familles voire des villages entiers,
qu'ils acheminent, toutes chaînes serrées, vers les divers souks de la maison de l'Islam.
Après la chute de l'Ibérie sous la férule du Coran, l'armée islamique poursuit son expansion vers la Gaule.
En 719, un gouverneur arabe nommé Samah franchit pour la première fois les Pyrénées.
Longeant la Méditerranée, il conquiert Narbonne puis étend son influence alentour.
Les musulmans ravagent les villes, incendient les bâtiments, violent les femmes,
emmènent des esclaves.
Pour beaucoup de victimes, c'est l'instant tragique de toute une vie.
Aveuglé par ses succès, Samah s'élance vers la Garonne pour prendre Toulouse.
Mais, contre toute attente, Toulouse résiste.
Le 9 juin 721, le duc Eudes remporte la première victoire de l'Occident chrétien
contre les Arabes islamiques.
Au cours de la mêlée, Samah est tué.
Les envahisseurs, repoussés mais non anéantis, s'enfuient derrière leur nouveau chef Abd al-Rahman.
Par cette victoire,
Eudes d'Aquitaine devient le sauveur de la civilisation chrétienne.
Le pape Grégoire II le félicite.
Si les musulmans avaient renoncé à la Gaule,
la postérité aurait sans doute gardé le souvenir d'Eudes.
Mais il va en être autrement.
Vers 725, depuis Barcelone qui leur sert de base arrière,
les Sarrasins se ruent à nouveau vers le Nord et s'empare cette fois des bouches du Rhône.
Cette intrusion fulgurante effraie des chefs politiques locaux.
Certains songent à trahir leur civilisation,
dont un certain Mauronte, qui fait office de maire de Marseille.
Plutôt que d'essayer de résister à l'envahisseur,
à l'exemple du duc Eudes,
Mauronte préfère acheter la paix,
il accepte la dhimma, il se fait dhimmi.
Il paie un tribut aux musulmans et leur remet des otages.
Or, la lâcheté est contagieuse.
Bientôt le doute se diffuse dans les consciences.
En cette 729,
Eudes se rapproche lui aussi des musulmans.
Le duc d'Aquitaine n'est certes pas un dhimmi, tel Mauronte,
mais il estime qu'une entente est possible avec certains musulmans.
Il sait qu'Arabes et Berbères ne s'aiment guère, les Arabes ayant en effet coutume de mépriser les peuples maghrébins.
Alors Eudes croit judicieux de marier sa fille Lampégie au petit chef berbère Munusa,
qui gouverne les Pyrénées orientales.
Mais cette alliance dynastique n'est pas du goût des deux chefs d'états voisins.
Tout au nord, Charles Martel s'interroge.
Pourquoi Eudes noue-t-il soudain des relations amicales avec ses ennemis d'hier ?
Après tout, si le chef de la Garonne voulait marier sa fille Lampégie,
pourquoi n'a-t-il pas pris contact avec l'aristocratie franque ?
Tout au sud, le chef islamique Abd al-Rahman se pose la même question.
Si Munusa voulait se marier,
que n'a-t-il épousé une princesse arabe et islamique à la place d'une duchesse gauloise et chrétienne ?
Pressé d'en finir avec ce simulacre de vivre ensemble,
Abd al-rahman
rassemble son armée et assaillent le menu domaine de Munusa.
La mêlée et brève, la victoire sans nuance.
Le roitelet berbère est capturé et décapité.
Quant à l'innocente Lampégie, elle paye le prix de la candeur de son père.
Réduite en esclavage, la fille d'Eudes d'Aquitaine est aussitôt expédiée au harem du khalife de Damas.
Charles se méfie du duc d'Aquitaine, qu'il juge sournois et comploteur.
Eudes en effet n'avait pas hésité à s'allier autrefois à Rainfroi puis naguère à Munusa.
Il n'y a qu'avec Charles qu'il ne voulait pas s'allier.
Alors le maire du palais de France lance une incursion en Aquitaine.
En 731, il pille le nord de la région et en ramène un solide butin.
La situation d'Eudes devient critique. Il a joué il a beaucoup perdu.
Désormais, il se voit pris en tenaille
entre le chef des Sarrasins au sud et le chef des Francs au nord.
Et les événements vont s'accélérer.
Abd al-Rahman cogite une nouvelle offensive sur la Gaule.
Il se souvient de l'échec des siens devant Toulouse en 721.
Il cherche une autre route vers le nord.
Début 732, son choix se porte sur la côte atlantique.
A la tête de son armée, il traverse les Pyrénées,
ravage le pays basque et, galopant de razzia en razzia, s'empare de Bordeaux.
Eudes, désemparé mais combatif, s'efforce d'opposer une résistance hardie le long de la Garonne.
Mais ses troupes sont insuffisantes.
Rapidement, il doit battre en retraite avec ses derniers hommes.
L'Aquitaine s'écroule. Abd al-Rahman triomphe. Poitiers subit le martyre des flammes.
En ligne de mire, les Sarrasins lorgnent sur la riche basilique Saint-Martin de Tours.
Vaincu mais vivant, le duc Eudes s'échappe vers le nord et sollicite l'aide de son ancien rival.
L'accueil que lui réserva Charles fut peut-être chaleureux.
Le césar déchu suscite désormais la pitié.
Dans sa chronique, Paul Diacre écrit :
Face à la menace sarrasine, les querelles de famille s'estompent.
Charles mobilise sans tarder son armée.
Les chevaliers Francs passent par Tours puis s'enfoncent dans les plaines du Poitou au devant de l'ennemi.
La rencontre entre l'armée chrétienne et l'armée islamique se situe près de Poitiers à Vouneuil-sur-Vienne,
au lieu-dit de Moussais-la-Bataille.
On est le 18 octobre 732.
Là, deux civilisations s'observent :
d'un côté, derrière Charles Martel, des hommes de race blanche, de religion chrétienne
et de langue européenne.
De l'autre, derrière Abd al-Rahman,
des hommes de race foncée, de religion islamique
et de langue sémitique.
Tout les sépare.
Pendant plusieurs jours, de part et d'autre, on s'adonne à des escarmouches,
on jauge la situation, on repère les points névralgiques.
Surtout, on attend.
Avant même les premiers chants d'épée, les probabilités de l'emporter divergent d'un camp à l'autre.
Charles a l'avantage du temps, il n'est pas pressé.
Il défend son propre pays avec l'appui de la population locale.
Pour lui, la question de l'intendance ne se pose pas.
Il trouvera toujours de quoi nourrir ses hommes et ses chevaux.
Il a même tout intérêt à vider les silos de la région, à emmener le grain, à déplacer les bestiaux en lieu sûr,
à pratiquer une politique de terre brûlée.
Son plan : pousser les Sarrasins à la faute.
Abd al-Rahman commence à douter de sa baraka.
Pour la première fois, il s'est enfoncé fort loin de son royaume ibérique.
Que sait-il de la Gaule,
ses rivières, ses ponts, ses routes, son relief ?
Et puis, il y a le problème de l'intendance.
Comment nourrir ses soldats et ses chevaux en terre hostile ?
Le prince mahométan est donc pousser à prendre l'initiative,
sur une terre qu'il ne connaît pas,
avec une logistique précaire,
loin des siens et sans secours à attendre.
Au glissement du crépuscule,
Abd al-Rahman se retire avec les siens.
Dans la solitude du pouvoir,
il pressent peut-être qu'il s'est aventuré trop loin.
Comment se déroula la bataille ? Une donnée technique offre peut être une ébauche de réponse.
C'est autour du VIIIe siècle que fut inventée l'étrier.
En offrant au chevalier une meilleure assise sur la selle, l'étrier permet de frapper d'estoc l'ennemi.
D'où cette nouveauté de tenir une longue de lance brandie en avant pour défoncer la cible.
Chose évidemment impossible sans étriers,
car le choc frontal aurait éjecté le chevalier en arrière.
Montés sur leurs chevaux, les Francs sont alignés en rangs serrés.
Il s'agit pour eux d'empêcher l'ennemi de se faufiler entre les lignes.
Les chevaliers de Charles Martel présente donc une densité massive.
De loin, les boucliers scintillent, tel un mur de glace réfléchissant la lumière.
Cette hypothèse semble confirmée par la chronique mozarabe :
Les chrétiens nordiques attendent le signal de leur chef.
Les Sarrasins, eux, sont déjà au galop. Ils approchent.
Soudain, sur ordre de Charles, résonnent trompettes et olifants.
Les Francs s'élancent et brandissent leurs hampes comme autant d'aiguillons meurtriers.
Dès le début de la mêlée, les pointes de fer percent les boucliers islamiques et embrochent la chair ennemie.
Dans les duels, Abd al'Rahman trouve la mort,
les envahisseurs sont écrasés,
Charles Martel triomphe.
La chronique de Frédégaire raconte :
La victoire des chrétiens est totale.
L'écho de cette bataille franchit bientôt les frontières.
Le Britannique Bède le Vénérable écrit :
Preuve du caractère civilisationnel de l'événement,
c'est suite à cette bataille que, pour la première fois,
des chroniqueurs utilisent le mot "Européens" pour évoquer les vainqueurs de Poitiers.
Poitiers jette donc les fondations de ce que sera l'Europe :
le continent de race blanche et de civilisation chrétienne.
Après Poitiers, toute la Chrétienté d'Europe chante les louanges de Charles Martel.
Et un halo de légende s'empare bientôt de cette fulgurante victoire.
Dans son palais, le prince des Francs organise un immense banquet,
où les anciens combattants racontent leur pétillantes aventures.
C'est à ce moment que Charles aurait reçu le surnom de "Martel".
Peut-être le marteau de Charles fait-il allusion à l'attribut d'un ancien dieu païen,
car les vieux mythes celtes étaient alors encore bien vivaces.
Assis à ces tables bruyantes, des trouvères
écoutent et mémorisent les exploits des soldats revenus du Poitou invincible.
Mêlant événements réels et contes anciens,
les jongleurs de mots vont donner naissance aux fameuses chansons de geste.
La mémoire ethnique fut toutefois ingrate envers Charles Martel,
car le VIIIe siècle va offrir à l'Europe un autre personnage haut en couleur,
qui est le petit-fils du champion de Poitiers.
Par un transfert épique d'un Charles à un autre Charles,
c'est Charlemagne qui est devenu le roi de la matière de France.
Pourtant les faits historiques sont pérennes :
le Charles, chef des armées franques et chrétiennes,
qui guerroya des années contre les Sarrasins islamiques,
ce n'est pas Charlemagne, qui pour sa part échangea avec eux d'amicales ambassades,
mais bien son aïeul le maire du palais.
Ainsi, dans les poèmes épiques, sous la célèbre barbe fleurie de l'empereur Charlemagne,
pointe en réalité la pilosité de Charles Martel.
Les chansons de geste étant les premiers textes d'importance en français,
cela pose la question de la date de naissance de la langue.
842 est la date la plus ancienne connue de vieux-français.
Il s'agit d'un document appelé le Serment de Strasbourg.
Ce serment fut prononcé à haute voix par Charles le Chauve et Louis le Germanique,
chacun dans la langue de l'autre et devant leurs peuples rassemblés, afin de se promettre une paix mutuelle.
Le texte français disait :
Si, en 842, existe une trace écrite de français
au point que l'on demande au roi Louis le Germanique de s'exprimer dans cette langue pour être compris du peuple de Charles le Chauve,
cela signifie que le peuple de Charles le Chauve parlait déjà couramment cette langue.
Lors du Serment de Strasbourg,
étaient présents des guerriers d'une trentaine d'années nés sous Charlemagne
et des hommes d'âge mûr nés sous Pépin le Bref,
et, comme il y eut toujours des centenaires,
s'il en fut un le jour de ce serment, cet honorable doyen était né sous Charles Martel.
Selon toute vraisemblance,
les prémices de la langue française orale remonte donc un siècle avant le Serment de Strasbourg, voire davantage.
Au banquet de Charles Martel, certaines tables parlaient déjà français.
Les plaines poitevines ont aussi conservé le souvenir de cette époque.
Après avoir bouté les Sarrasins hors de Gaule,
Charles Martel se serait rendu dans la chapelle Sainte-Catherine-de-Fierbois au sud de Tours.
Dans cette église, le glorieux maire du palais offre à Dieu son épée, qu'il dépose
précieusement au pied de l'autel.
Le temps passe
et, pour de nombreux siècles, recouvre cette sainte lame du sceau de l'oubli.
Mais, quand le royaume connaîtra de nouveaux tourments, en 1429, les voix du Ciel
révéleront à Jeanne d'Arc
l'existence du glaive de Charles Martel et où le trouver.
Voici ce qu'elle dit lors de son procès :
La Pucelle, qui libérera Orléans du joug anglais, aurait tenu en main l'épée du vainqueur de Poitiers.
La victoire de Poitiers n'est pas une fin en soi, mais le début de la reconquête.
C'est l'aube de la renaissance occidentale.
Beaucoup restait à accomplir.
Youssef, le fils d'Abd al-Rahman, gouvernait alors Narbonne.
Habile diplomate,
il avait noué des liens avec Mauronte, le maire de Marseille.
Et Mauronte, politicien lâche, lui avait cédé Avignon.
De là, certains Sarrasins ont commencé d'explorer les berges du Rhône et même au delà :
Valence, Vienne, Lyon, Autun...
Pour enrayer cette intrusion étrangère,
dès 733, Charles martel déploie des contingents militaires dans le Sud-Est.
Avec son armée, il entre en Burgondie et y place des fidèles aux divers postes de commandement.
Là, il délègue son autorité à son frère Childebrand, qui devient duc de Burgondie.
En 735, Eudes meurt de vieillesse.
Son fils Hunaut lui succède sur le duché d'Aquitaine,
après avoir dû prêter hommage à Charles Martel.
Si l'on tire un bilan politique, en 735, Charles Martel étend son gouvernement à presque toute la Gaule.
Il en tient personnellement la moitié nord (Austrasie et Neustrie),
Son frère Childebrand dirige la Burgondie et s'efforce de libérer la Provence,
et Hunaut d'Aquitaine reconnaît la souveraineté des Francs.
Mais, toutes ces années, les côtes méditerranéennes ont souffert des ravages islamiques.
Les griffes du Coran enserrent Avignon, et Childebrand peine à pacifier le delta du Rhône.
Alors, en 737, Charles descend sur les routes du soleil avec du matériel de guerre
et délivre la cité.
Il est possible que ce matériel de sièges,
apporté par Charles Martel, soit aussi l'occasion de tester une innovation technologique.
Jadis, au temps des Romains, pour projeter de grosses masses, on usait de catapultes.
L'inconvénient de ce type d'engin, c'est que son énergie dépend de l'élasticité d'un ressort,
fait de bois tendre ou d'un nerf de boeuf.
Or, sous le climat pluvieux de la Gaule,
L'humidité risque de détendre le ressort de la machine et de la rendre inopérante.
D'où l'invention de la perrière au Haut Moyen Age.
Cet engin astucieux présente une hélice sur un axe vertical
une corde, actionnée vigoureusement par quelques hommes, fait tourner cette hélice,
ce qui éjecte de la poche de cuir un boulet de quelques kilos.
On atteint ainsi une cible à 60 mètres, à la cadence de 60 tirs à l'heure.
L'avantage de la perrière sur la catapulte, c'est qu'elle est utilisable par tous les temps, même sous la pluie.
Comme pour l'étrier, les machines de guerre à balancier ouvre une nouvelle ère dans l'art de la guerre.
Vaincus et pourchassés par les Francs, les Sarrasins évacuent la Provence et se replient sur Narbonne.
Derrière ses murailles,
Youssef, fils d'Abd al-Rahmane, s'est puissamment retranché.
Et il a eu la prudence
d'appeler à son secours
les troupes islamiques restées en Espagne.
Pour Charles Martel, le péril est sérieux.
Il sait Narbonne difficile à prendre.
Parant au plus pressé, il laisse quelques troupes autour de la cité
et marche avec le gros de l'armée au devant des renforts mahométans.
C'est dans la vallée des Corbières, près des rivières de la Berre et de l'Aude, que se déroule la bataille.
Omar ibn Khaled, le général sarrasin, y trouve la mort.
Ses soldats sont massacrés ou tentent de s'enfuir par les eaux, souvent en vain.
Cette victoire de la Berre sonne le glas des velléités islamiques sur la Gaule.
La Septimanie est libérée.
Seule Narbonne résistera encore quelques temps,
avant d'être reconquise, en 759, par Pépin le Bref, fils de Charles Martel.
Tant de malheurs fut le fruit, certes, de la témérité sarrasine,
mais aussi de la trahison de certaines élites locales.
Une fois la Gaule délivrée, Charles Martel venge l'infamie et punit les félons.
Il cherche notamment le fameux Mauronte, ce chef marseillais qui avait choisi le statut de dhimmi.
Mais le judas de la Provence avait pris soin de préparer ses arrières,
il courut se terrer dans les calanques, d'où il ne revint jamais.
Au sortir des guerres islamiques des années 730, les Sarrasins sont les grands perdants.
Abd al-Rahman a été vaincu et tué dans le Poitou.
Son fils Youssef survit difficilement derrière les murailles de Narbonne.
Omar ibn Khaled et son armée ont disparu dans les marécages du Languedoc.
Côté chrétien, les plus irrésolus connurent un sort déplorable.
Eudes, le vainqueur de Toulouse, avait fini par renoncer à la lutte, il fut balayé par la tornade de 732.
Sa fille Lampégie termina ses jours dans un lointain harem.
Mauronte, le traître de Marseille, avait choisi la soumission à l'ennemi, il dut s'exiler dans des lieux sauvages.
L'histoire a donné raison à Charles Martel.
Sa stratégie offensive et persévérante était la bonne.
Son audace technique a payé.
Le royaume chrétien des Francs émerge des luttes civilisationnelles,
plus fort et plus rayonnant que jamais.
En 737, le roi fainéant Thierry IV décède.
Charles prend alors une décision
aussi prudente que hardie, il ne le remplace pas.
La France devient un royaume sans roi, une situation inédite.
Le maire du palais échafaude en fait un coup politique à longue portée.
Ambitieux, il a mainte fois nourri la tentation de se faire sacrer roi,
mais un coup d'Etat l'eût entraîné dans un tourbillon d'incertitude.
En ne proclamant roi ni un nouveau mérovingien ni lui même,
le chef des Francs ménage la puissante aristocratie, tout en préparant avec patience,
sinon pour lui du moins pour sa propre descendance, les marches du sacre royal.
La désuétude d'en référer à la dynastie mérovingienne,
tôt ou tard,
profitera à la lignée du vainqueur de Poitiers. Tout n'est que question de temps
En attendant, il confie l'éducation de ses fils, Carloman et Pépin le bref,
à l'influente basilique Saint-Denis.
Les rapports entre Charles Martel et l'Eglise sont ambigus et reflètent les dérèglements moraux de l'époque.
Dépassant les limites de son champ d'action politique, le maire du palais n'hésite pas à empiéter sur les privilèges du Clergé.
Au IXe siècle, l'historien Flodoard écrit :
Il ne s'agit ni de pillage ni d'une razzia sur les objets du culte, mais d'un abus de pouvoir.
On accuse Charles de nommer des laïcs à la tête de la puissance foncière du Clergé
et d'en tirer de précieux dividendes au profit de la noblesse.
Or, ces accusations ne sont pas infondées.
Charles Martel a pour compagnon d'aventure un moine du nom de Milon.
Ce curieux personnage remplit à ses côtés la fonction de conseiller et de diplomate,
en plus de participer activement aux batailles.
En récompense de ses loyaux services, le chef des Francs le propulse évêque de Reims.
Sauf que cette charge exige que Milon soit prêtre, ce qu'il n'est pas.
D'où la plainte justifiée de Flodoard :
Le moine Milon, homme de confiance de Charles Martel, est il une exception ?
Loin d'être un cas à part, c'est la hiérarchie même de l'Eglise qui s'adonne parfois au plaisir séculier des armes.
Ainsi, durant la guerre civile de 714-720, l'évêque Savaric d'Auxerre prit la tête d'une milice
et s'en partit conquérir des villes. Il s'empara d'Orléans, de Troyes, d'Avalon.
On ignore ses motivations et ses alliances. Peut-être cherchait-il à devenir maire du palais de Burgondie.
Toujours est-il que l'évêque d'Auxerre se préparaient à envahir la région lyonnaise, quand il perdit la vie.
Comme on peut le constater, qu'il s'agisse de Milon de Reims ou de Savaric d'Auxerre,
les hommes de Dieu ne se cantonnent pas toujours aux lieux de prière.
Et il n'est pas rare de voir l'épée pendre à la soutane.
La Nation a conservé le souvenir de Milon dans la poésie des chansons de geste,
à travers le truculent Turpin de La Chanson de Roland.
Milon et Turpin sont tous deux évêques de Reims,
tous deux luttent l'épée à la main dans les mêlées,
et tous deux servent à la cour d'un chef des Francs du nom de Charles.
A ceci près que Milon est au service de Charles Martel, Turpin sera au service de Charlemagne.
Le VIIIe siècle entremêlait parfois les fonctions du clerc et du guerrier.
On peut en souligner la licence, mais on ne saurait reprocher à Charles Martel d'avoir mordu les privilèges d'un Clergé
qui n'était pas irréprochable.
Pour se convaincre des sentiments réels de l'Eglise envers le vainqueur de Poitiers,
il suffit de se tourner vers la papauté de l'époque.
Grégoire III est l'évêque de Rome de 731 à 741.
En 739, le pape dépêche auprès du chef des Francs deux ambassades chargées d'objets de valeur.
C'est là une initiative tellement insolite qu'elle stupéfie les contemporains :
Loin de le blâmer pour quelque abus que ce soit,
Grégoire III adresse au contraire ses plus insistantes louanges au vainqueur de Poitiers.
De Charles Martel
le Saint-Père sollicite protection contre les impies sarrasins
et contre le peuple des Lombards, qui tient le nord de l'Italie.
Il cherche aussi à s'extraire de la tutelle byzantine.
Le chef des Francs est donc non seulement le sauveur de l'Occident chrétien
mais, de son temps même, le pape en personne l'honore en lui décernant le titre de protecteur de l'Eglise.
Bientôt, vient l'heure du rappel à Dieu.
Ayant contracté une maladie,
Charles Martel rend le dernier souffle le 22 octobre 741.
Il a 53 ans.
Quel destin !
Fils illégitime du maire du palais Pépin le Gros, Charles fut jeté en prison à la mort de son père.
A 26 ans, il entame une longue marche vers le pouvoir.
Il remporte entre 716 et 719 trois batailles majeures contre ses rivaux politiques
et assoit ainsi son autorité sur la Gaule.
A partir des années 720, il protège de son épée les missionnaires chrétiens partis enseigner les saintes écritures en Germanie.
En 732, à Poitiers, il écrase les Sarrasins musulmans,
puis, en 737, il les chasse de la côte méditerranéenne.
Au crépuscule de sa vie, il reçoit du pape les plus précieux éloges.
Et pourtant, Charles Martel ne fut jamais roi.
Toujours, il se retint de commettre une imprudence et se contenta de commander aux rois.
Comme l'écrira au XVIe siècle le poète Ronsard :
Pépin le Bref, fils de Charles Martel,
sera élevé sur le pavois en 751,
opérant le changement dynastique.
La couronne de France passe alors des Mérovingiens aux Carolingiens, dont le nom provient de Charles.
L'ascension de la lignée carolingienne est fulgurante.
A Saint-Denis, le 28 juillet 754,
Pépin le Bref reçoit sur le front, des mains du pape Etienne II,
la sainte huile qui fait de lui un roi de droit divin.
Le 25 décembre 800, à Noël,
Charlemagne, fils de Pépin le Bref, est sacré empereur d'Occident.
Même si Charles Martel ne fut jamais roi,
il fut le père du premier roi de France sacré par un pape
et le grand-père du premier empereur d'Europe.
Un tel destin est inégalée dans l'histoire de notre continent.